four
environmentally friendly lawn mowers at
work for the city of paris
the sheep keep the grass short on
undeveloped plots of land
without endangering the small animals
living there
the sheba currently grazing on a lot
near the city archives
the head of the archives herself and
animal lover brought them here
she hopes the sheik will prove to be
more than insect-friendly lawn groomers
people don't know us we're back from the
street and the way isn't well signposted
it was designed that way for security
reasons the sheep help us to show people
look here's some green space perfect for
a picnic
and if you're a little curious you can
take a peek in our conference room
naturally these aren't run-of-the-mill
domestic sheep
next to choice cows and pigs they're
bred here at this farm operated by the
city of paris
this breed of breton dwarf sheep was
once virtually extinct
these sheep stay small so you can forget
using them for meat
but they have other benefits they're
robust
and almost never get sick and they eat
everything imaginable
even plants with little protein
until now cars not animals had priority
in paris
even the banks of the river sen were
paved to facilitate the flow of traffic
pollution became so bad that parisians
decided to take action
many voted for the green party in the
last local elections
far more than usually do in france
the green city councillors declared war
on traffic and began cultivating green
spaces in the city
now they're basking in their success
the city has even become a place of
refuge for various animal species
the agricultural areas surrounding the
city are so contaminated with pesticides
that the animals prefer to come to paris
foxes in particular are often seen in
the city
and species like the soprano pipistrelle
a bat once rare in paris
find the french capital increasingly
attractive
even the timetable of construction work
has been altered on their account
at this construction site they work day
and night for months to be finished
before winter set in
now around 500 of the little bats can
hibernate here undisturbed by the
vibrations of construction equipment
few parisians ever come face to face
with a soprano pepestral
this one was nursed back to health by a
parisian student
after it broke its wing
but for animal rights activists the
city's animal protection initiatives
don't go far enough
they say some animals are getting a
rough deal
the city council doesn't like stray cats
a few years ago there were lots of
untagged cats in my district
but then the city sent out animal
catchers and from one day to the next
the cats were gone
except for mara here who i rescued when
there are too many of one kind of animal
people get frightened
especially people at city hall
at paris city hall staff say they've
done nothing wrong
it's part of the concept that the
numbers of any single species
shouldn't get out of hand that's why
peregrine falcons have been brought in
to drive out many of the thousands of
pigeons now living in paris
in june atop a smokestack at a paris
heating plant
a brood of peregrine chicks was born a
first for the city
if you told me a decade ago that there'd
be peregrines in paris
i'd never have believed it they're birds
that normally
only live in the wild
residents seem to appreciate the
initiative more animals in paris
albeit with certain reservations
the pigeons are a nuisance but they've
been largely exterminated in paris
so things are much better now as long as
they don't make a mess
other animals don't bother me
in parkland that's good then you don't
need to mow the grass
they're wild animals in the city like
squirrels
those kind of animals okay as long as
they don't hurt us
one of the world's oldest taxidermist
shops they say that animals are
currently fashionable in paris
interior decorators are clamoring for
prepared and stuffed animals
the britain dwarf sheep is still missing
from their extensive collection of
mounted animals
but then these woolly creatures are
still needed alive
elsewhere